you don't change your box of action so
don't go in and back out
keep up forward in inches forward
deviates there to face in so my butt
that dislike the manifestation make
contact again follow it follow it here
on this side seam not gonna meet my
Glock here on this side
why check contact line check skewer same
thing again
hot line
that's a clutch or training hey we ought
to stop the embryonic
in my yard he's moved and I was not
connected then I come back and he
connect my was following him Suba so
when he he's gonna swing his arm this is
a lever I can be on the range no problem
are you talk to lover at the sword but
can't be and it's a peg oh I'm gonna
hurt sing then it's gonna be a class
okay so I can be on a range or catch you
in the sword did I'm not clashing with
it this is I so then I'm blending with
his sword cut not clashing with his
sword
so his butt is going down I keep on
piling Zach don't retreat smothering
[Music]
yeah I make contact here reach the
starter do ITT and then I can't stay
there because that's I'm gonna create
another juji with his weapon
I need Yuji on this side not to see
underneath juji's the 10 character which
is the problem okay so I'm this GG you
see hey this goes down with him oh look
at my height hey I'll feel them touch
then I start to yield with it go back we
go watch your toes here
I want that Bigfoot vector oh but I want
to go down all the way
that's what if I think if you go down to
moves this is dispositive I do the pie
pan so I can continue the chat so he's
not mobile and you can't deviate Olesky
oh I'm faster coming in then here is not
all the way down then you just call
anything that does is allows you to
drill the skill you want more
efficiently because you don't have to
stop and start over and you get to learn
from different places so you get rid of
the beginning and ending okay so the
main thing we want is that
reconciliation his young energy comes in
and boom
I let that go and he goes on wool so not
here oh boom and then I get
skewered know if she's dependent on me
being checked out so that's where i
reconcile slow
it's my unwillingness to change my level
that creates the check it's not his
energy it's the combination I staying
here he goes down to the check me then
I'm Stuart so I changed my side of the
equation change my hi home then it just
he did check me he Diaries checked
[Music]
you you support around
a lot of young so my whole my sword is
going to take advantage of his speed
I'm going okay here we are
where'd you make contact all right feel
and go around same same rule down
sometimes there's energy drink okay
same rule contact underneath but not
lifting then Gigi on the side not 2g
this way to here don't lift this weapon
then your speed is back make his weapon
slow
see how much freedom I have
see the different the live part the
beginning of the set is very impressive
shut them down if I don't he's going to
be possible when that's your job when
you resist your house you get good
okay